hey 42 here nobody enjoys having surgery
except maybe that woman who spent
millions of dollars trying to make
herself look like a cat
but on the whole it's something we all
do our best to try and avoid
but if for whatever reason we do find
ourselves being wheeled into the
operating theatre
we should count ourselves lucky that we
live in an age where anesthetics and
good hygiene are both regarded as pretty
essential commodities
within the medical world because imagine
if you will a time and place where
having an operation
meant being wide awake as a man wearing
a blood-soaked apron
hacked through your leg with a dirty saw
whilst a crowd of onlookers
watched you screaming in agony that
might sound like a scene from a horror
film
but in fact it was very much a reality
in victorian england
where talk of potions that could put you
into an unshakable sleep would have
sounded like
sorcery and the idea of washing your
hands before an operation
was as laughable as suggesting children
of six
were too young to work operating
theaters were
overcrowded stuffy unhygienic
auditoriums that were often packed with
medical students
fellow surgeons and even paying visitors
all of whom were there to witness what
was practically a blood sport
these days we expect our surgeons to
take the utmost care as they
jab our prone bodies with their scalpels
but in a world without anesthetic where
every second brings the kind of agony
that can
push a human being to their very limits
and beyond
it doesn't pay to dawdle in fact
speed was absolutely vital to the
success of each and every major
procedure
the faster a surgeon could complete the
task at hand
the less chance there was of their
patients dying of shock
or blood loss and when it came to speed
one name stood out above all of us
robert liston liston was the usain
bolt of the 19th century medical world
known as the fastest knife in the west
end
it was claimed he could amputate a limb
in less than a minute
liston was born in scotland in 1794
where he would go on to study medicine
at the university of edinburgh
it was here he took an interest in human
anatomy
and his love affair with chopping off
limbs at breakneck
speeds began by the late 1820s he'd
risen through the ranks to become one of
the most celebrated surgeons of his era
liston was an imposing character over
six feet tall
with a bullish attitude that was said to
strike fear
into the hearts of his students before
carrying out an amputation he would
stride across the blood-stained floors
of his operating theater
before holding his knife aloft turning
to his audience
and uttering his catchphrase yes he had
a catchphrase
time me gentlemen time me
the audience's eyes would flit between
their pocket watches
and listen as he went to work his
blood-drenched scalpel gripped between
his teeth
as he skillfully carved through the
patient's limb with a bone saw
of course this hack and slash approach
to surgery
meant the occasional mishap was
inevitable
and even a surgeon of liston's caliber
could be expected to have an
off day every now and then during
one tear-jerking incident he set about
removing a lump from a young boy's neck
only to discover too late that it was
connected to a major artery
the mishap resulted in the boy
tragically bleeding to death
in front of horrified onlookers on
another occasion that's also likely to
bring tears to your eyes
but for entirely different reasons he
accidentally sliced off a patient's
testicles
whilst performing a full leg amputation
as bad as those two slip-ups were
listen's most disastrous day at the
office
is widely regarded as one of the biggest
surgical mishaps
in history
during one of his famed lightning fast
amputations
liston not only managed to chop off his
hapless patient's leg
but also a few of his assistant's
fingers
in the ensuing chaos liston's knife
accidentally slashed through an elderly
spectator's coat
the man was so certain he'd been
mortally wounded
he passed out and later died of shock
both the patient and the assistant with
the missing fingers
would also die later as a result of
infection
giving glisten the unwelcome distinction
of accidentally killing free people
during a single surgical procedure a
record which
to this day is yet to be broken that's
not a challenge to any budding surgeons
out there by the way
and i should point out that some
historians believe this story
may be apocryphal the fact that two of
these deaths were caused by
infection is telling most surgeons
failed to wash their hands or their
surgical instruments
before performing surgery simply
believing it to be
unnecessary surgeons in the mid-19th
century had such a poor understanding of
the importance of hygiene
that wearing a blood-soaked apron
bearing the congealed
gore from past operations was considered
something of a badge of honor
after all if your apron was so matted
with dried blood and guts that it was
able to stand up by itself
you were clearly in serious demand and
had probably
been hacking off body parts successfully
for many years
to make masses even worse after the
traumatic experience of having something
chopped off a patient was taken to
recover on an unsanitary hospital ward
where their freshly festering wound was
left exposed
and at the mercy of nasty bacteria that
happened to be knocking around
with nothing better to do as a result
gangrene and blood poisoning were both
extremely common
the air of your average ward was thick
with the smell of bodily fluids and
rotting flesh
and bed bugs were so rife that bug
destroyers were often paid more than the
surgeons themselves
with such a high proportion of patients
either dying
during or after surgery it was clear
that
something needed to be done liston
himself was a practical man
who didn't concern himself too much with
the scientific side of what he did
he was the embodiment of old-school
blood and gut surgery
if something needed removing he could do
it fast
and efficiently and almost every time he
managed to leave the patient's balls
intact
exactly where they should be but that
didn't mean liston was averse to
progress
and it was two of his students james
simpson
and joseph lister he would go on to have
a huge impact on
how surgery was performed after
following in liston's footsteps
but more on those two in a moment if the
harrowing
sound of a patient screaming on the
operating table
was to become a thing of the past a way
of nullifying
pain during surgery needed to be found
we humans have been finding new and
unique ways to knock ourselves out
for literally thousands of years opium
alcohol and cannabis have all been used
to
alleviate us of our senses for time
immemorial
but the first reliably recorded attempt
at using anesthesia
specifically for surgery actually came
all the way back
in 1804 when japanese surgeon
hanoka seishu carried out a successful
mastectomy with an anesthetic based on
various plant extracts
but over in the west surgeons were
experimenting with
more eccentric alternatives
one of the most cutting edge of which
was something called
mesmerism the brainchild of a man called
franz mesmer
mesmer believed an invisible force
flowed through all living
things and that this force could be used
to
make people fall into a deep sleep
whether or not he also carried a
lightsaber
has never been confirmed once in this
state
it was claimed that a patient could be
operated on
without feeling any pain by the way all
you etymology fans out there
might like to know that mesmerism gave
us the modern word
mesmerize anyway for a brief time
mesmerism
is said to have actually yielded some
positive results
and it became popular enough that it was
considered by some
to be a legitimate pain preventative
during surgery
but mesmer's magical force would soon
have a rival that was more
firmly rooted in science fact than
science fiction an organic compound
known as ether ether was first housed as
a possible solution to the
terror of someone having to watch
themselves being sliced up like a roast
chicken
after its ability to make people
unconscious was popularized
during so-called ether frolics
which were essentially public gatherings
where groups of people would take
turns inhaling the vapor from
sweet-smelling liquid
in order to knock themselves out for a
bit
which doesn't sound too dissimilar to
what goes on down at my local on a
friday night
the first public use of ether as an
anesthetic was by american dentist
william morton
who used it whilst extracting a
patient's tooth in 1846
it had actually been used by a surgeon
named crawford long about
four years earlier but bizarrely he
didn't seem to think it was
anything worth writing home about and
failed to document his results
although he did change his tune when
other people started to take the
plaudits for what he argued was
his discovery shock
news of this miracle drug spread fast
and back in london robert liston
heralded
a new age of surgery when he performed
the world's first
pain-free amputation this
landmark procedure was so successful
that when the patient regained
consciousness
he was unaware the operation had ever
taken place
this would lead liston to famously
proclaim
this yankee dodge beats mesmerism hollow
in other words hypnotic mind tricks were
out
and ether was in but
ether was not without its drawbacks it's
highly flammable
and irritates the lungs when inhaled
although great strides had been made
there was still room for improvement and
that's where the first of listen
students
james simpson comes in apparently people
in the 19th century really enjoyed
inhaling things until they passed out
some things never change after a night
of huffing chloroform with a couple of
his mates
simpson felt sure he'd discovered a much
improved alternative to ether since
chloroform
wasn't flammable and it didn't irritate
the lungs
but its real ace in the hole was that
its effects
lasted longer meaning it could be used
to enable more advanced
surgical procedures i should probably
mention that despite the game-changing
properties of these new anesthetics
not everyone fought for the hole putting
people to sleep during surgery thing
was a good idea some surgeons believed
it was
necessary for patients to remain awake
in order to
fight for their lives so to speak but
when global trendsetter queen victoria
was given chloroform during the birth of
her two children
suddenly it was all the rage and anyone
who is anyone wouldn't be seen
dead having surgery without it it's
amazing what a bit of celebrity
endorsement can do for a product eh
of course literally being seen dead was
still a pretty high probability
although ether and chloroform had paved
the way for longer
and less scream inducing surgical
procedures
there was still a small matter of dying
from
infection afterwards the problem was
people were yet to figure out
just how exactly things like disease and
infection spread and if you don't know
how something spreads
you're pretty much powerless to stop it
from doing so
the most prominent hypothesis for how
disease made its way into the human body
was miasma theory the idea that
invisible noxious gases or bad air
floated around waiting to be inhaled by
unsuspecting victims
this bad air was believed to be emitted
from decaying organic matter
and in hospitals the only real
preventative in place to stop this
invisible killer was to crack open a
window
we still use this technique today to
great effect when someone lets rip in
the car
but it's safe to say it counts for very
little if you're lying in a filthy
bug-infested bed with your gaping wound
wrapped in dirty bandages still
he doesn't enjoy a nice breeze the idea
that
tiny microorganisms might be responsible
for the spread of disease
had been around since the late middle
ages but had never gained much
popularity
with the mighty miasma theory always
reigning supreme
french microbiologist louis pasteur
first proposed his germ theory
in 1861 after he conducted experiments
that suggested
the fermentation of organic matter was
caused by
particles in the air and not
as miasma theory would have it the air
itself
but the idea that tiny organisms could
destroy a mighty human being
seemed preposterous to many and at first
pastor's theory was not well received
a few years later over in germany
another microbiologist by the name of
robert kosh
was able to successfully isolate the
different pathogens responsible
for particular diseases and as a result
germ theory finally started to gain real
traction
the second of liston students joseph
lister
had been following these groundbreaking
developments with great interest
and he began to theorize that if he
could keep an operating theatre as
germ-free
as possible perhaps the likelihood of
infection
could be decreased he just needed to
find something that was
effective at killing those tiny little
buggers
the solution would present itself in the
most unlikely of places
the carlisle sewage works the place to
go for all your sanitary needs
lister heard from a colleague that
carbolic acid was being used to control
the overwhelming stench that was being
emitted from the sewage works
lister realized that in a more diluted
form
carbolic acid could be used safely
during surgical procedures and so he
began testing its
germ killing properties during his
operations
surgical instruments bandages and even
his own hands were all
drenched in the stuff he even had a
spray bottle handy so the acid could
continually be
pumped into the air during the operation
at first he was ridiculed for these
methods
but soon the results began to speak for
themselves
in just three years he took the death
rate of his patients from almost
50 percent down to 15
and before long his germ-busting
procedures
would be implemented in hospitals around
the world
these days safer and more effective
alternatives to carbolic acid and
chloroform
are in use but the principles laid down
by lister and simpson still remain in
place
hospitals today are bastions of good
hygiene
surgery is painless at least whilst it's
taking place
and operating theaters are about as
sterile as we can make them
not to mention free from prying
onlookers
operations can last for hours and in
extreme cases
even several days something that would
have been
unimaginable in robert liston's day
where his speed was of the essence
unfortunately liston would die as a
result of an aneurysm
at the peak of his career just one year
after he'd performed his
game-changing pain-free amputation
tragically this meant he would never see
the huge impact that he and
this landmark operation would have both
on his students
and on the medical world as a whole
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts
link in the description below thanks